[Applaudissements]
enfin les enfants bonsoir les au foro
bon le seul et didon nounours tu es bien
pressés ou dix patrons mais deux petites
amies m'attendent et je sais qu'ils
m'ont préparé une surprise alors
dépêche-toi a tout de suite aux propos
moi je suis les professeurs et moi la
lèves tu dois répondre à mes questions
approchez vous moquez bonjour madame tel
arrêté il est midi qui vous l'a dit la
petite forêt ou doc était à la chapelle
qu'est ce que lui fait de la dentelle
pour ti corps le dame de paris qui
portent des souliers gris ouvre moi les
petits les fenêtres et coincé
la plus belle la plus belle période la
plus élevée
au soir le petit dans son immense tu
fais pas tu dis ça vous paraît oui on en
sait plusieurs
assiettes et écoute celui de la souris
verte je suis tout ouïe l'eau une souris
verte qui courait dans l'herbe
je l'attrapé par là que je la montre a
fait messieurs ces messieurs mais 10h30
péladeau lui le groupe est là dans l'eau
sarver rennes escargots touchant bravo
les enfants que c'est joli on te dira
encore des autres et maintenant les
petites souris
l'ennui chronos bonne nuit mon cher
petit là
j'éteins la lumière
7pour
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors nounours et cette surprise nicolas
et pimprenelle mon resitue un groupe
pas trop ils en savent des choses
la pruche allant en route oui on route
vivement les vacances pas trop qu'on se
repose un peu oui nounours bonne nuit
les enfants allez vite vous couchez
embrasse bien fort votre papa eu votre
maman et
c'est deux pour un
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]